now dr tiff thoughts on the choices and
the lists and the process
please well i think it's natural
to kind of have some standards have some
non-negotiables that she has
that say hey this is what i'm looking
for but what tends to happen in
relationships and what i
what i tend to think is happening here
is that it is quite possible
to be so um dependent on your list that
you miss a lot of the signs
that are coming at you and this is an
opportunity for her
to do some self work to fix those things
so that when mr wright comes along
she's absolutely ready for him i think
we all walk into a relationship feeling
like okay this is what i want
but we don't necessarily always consider
that hey this is what i
need in this moment and so that's what i
would challenge theresa to do is really
think about what her needs are versus
what her
wants are and is a typical pitfall dr
tiff to say like these these are the
things that i want and you mentioned
something that really stuck out to me is
that you can miss signs can you
elaborate on that a little bit because i
really love right
right it is not wrong to want what you
want
and one of uh teresa's points was i want
someone who
is financially responsible absolutely
nothing wrong with that but when we look
at that
let's think about the why why do you
want someone who is financially
responsible i would suspect
i might guess you want someone who's
financially responsible
because someone has really taken
advantage of you financially in the past
so what you really are looking for is
not someone who's financially
responsible
but someone who has integrity so let's
push financially responsible to the side
and say i want a person with integrity
absolutely yeah you're dead on dr
tiff can you speak to finding balance in
a relationship
and the importance of that absolutely so
some folks feel like that
when we say balance is like lowering
your standards i i want what i want i
should always want that and
there shouldn't be a problem with that i
don't really see it as lowering your
standards i think we all have standards
but we're all very much
layered right i am not the sum of three
things on anybody's checklist
and i don't think you are drew and i
don't think you are theresa so we have
to look past
those three or four things and say okay
this person
is this but do they meet my values do we
connect on maybe a spiritual level
because i didn't see anything spiritual
on the list
but that doesn't mean that's not
important to you so we have to say
okay these are kind of bare minimum
standards that i have
but am i open to considering that the
perfect person
may not have a lot of this but maybe
really well endowed on some other things
that are really really important to me
um i think we all went to a certain
place when you said that
um i know i did because i'm a 13 year
old boy
living inside of a 40 year old 45 year
old woman
um great i know that's why the sense of
humor is
god i think it's always been my number
one uh
absolutely i also think you have got to
get any toxic rhetoric
out of your head that something about
you and your story is broken
or doesn't work you want to have
children that's a choice that's
empowering
motherhood is just as wonderful but you
happen to be
on the side of this is a goal and a
dream that's personal to you
that's not a flaw that has to do with
anyone else
and your age and your gender and your
you know confines of what it is to be a
woman like
that's just the reality and it's
beautiful
so you have a beautiful journey and
story
and it has yet also to reveal so many
chapters absolutely thank you
and i had my first daughter at 37 and my
second daughter at 38
and so you know who knows where this
story goes
i know that's why i was so excited when
um when you guys invited me on i was so
excited because i do know
a decent amount about your story and i
was like oh my gosh i can relate to her
so well
so thank you for having me on i am
so excited to talk about relationships
and
it's really exciting for me to talk to
dr tiff
as well because i've watched you speak
in other forums and
i always really like what you have to
say
and i trust what you tell people
yeah i appreciate that i think that you
know relationships are hard
and so you really are i believe teresa
doing your best
you know and you're going to have some
duds you're going to go into
relationship and think that you've
selected
appropriately and realized that oh this
was not what i thought it was
um but i i do hear from you that you're
open to being open
and you're open to exploring things that
aren't necessarily on your list but also
may be exactly what you need at this
time in your life absolutely
and this is your life so teresa
thank you for coming and
being with us i'd love to check in and
see how things are going if you don't
mind
absolutely i would love that excellent
and dr
tip thank you for coming on with all of
your wisdom and expertise
of course any time all right for more of
dr tiff's dating tips by the way
please come to our website at
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
and they'll be there
[Music]